hello in this video we'll talk about
obesity
obesity is a complex disease involving
an excessive amount of body fat
obesity isn't just a cosmetic concern
it's a medical problem that increases
the risk of other diseases as well
so obesity can be estimated by
calculating the body mass index
so our pmi bmi is a ratio of weight of
the body expressed in kgs divided by
height of the individual in meter square
so this ratio is
indicative of your body mass so if this
ratio is l lesser than 25
it is considered normal if it is greater
than
25 and it is in between 30 then you are
slightly overweight
if this ratio is more than 30 then you
are obese
obesity is life-threatening because it
is associated with several other
diseases such as heart attack stroke
type 2 diabetes cancers etc in simple
words obesity is the silent killer
according to cdc 40 percent of the
population in u.s has a high chance of
developing
obesity which is a big concern
we need calories for our functioning and
the calories comes from
food we take such as carbohydrate
protein or fat that gives us the energy
we need to keep ourselves going
but the problem occurs when we eat more
and spend less
in simple words we exercise less
so in that situation
body stores the excess energy in other
forms
so it also matters what kind of food we
eat whether we are eating healthy food
versus unhealthy food
when we
eat more calories and we are able to
burn less calorie then we are at a state
of calorific excess
body can deal with these excess calories
in three possible ways
first of all it can convert the excess
fuel to fat and store it in an adipose
tissue
second body can burn the fuel
by doing exercise lastly
there could be wastage of this excess
fuel via production of heat
now our body is evolutionary trained to
store excess calories in terms of fat
because in the early days there was
not so much of availability of food so
whenever body has some amount of calorie
which is excess it would store it for
the future that worked like a
survival strategy in the past
but nowadays we have plenty of food so
we never
go to a state where
we are devoid of food or devoid of
calories
excess calories along with sedentary
lifestyle
created a huge problem and this is the
result
we are getting obese
in our population the
fraction of obese people are increasing
day by day
dealing with obesity requires proper
knowledge
and we need to understand
what are the checks and balances that
our body applies to control the body
weight
because many of these mechanisms are
compromised
in obese individuals
so there is a lipostat hypothesis
it turns out our body can estimate how
much fat we have
and it try to keep the fat in a balanced
state known as set point
now when our fat level increase or
decrease our body can sense that by a
plethora of sensors
these sensors can interact with several
molecular
players
and ultimately it can bring down the fat
or bring up the fat
into a set point level and this
homeostatic mechanism is crucial for
weight management
obviously we can understand in obese
individuals
one possible
aspect is the defect of these lipostat
mechanisms
one such sensor
is leptin which is a hormone secreted by
adipose tissues itself this hormone
carries a message that fat reserves are
sufficient so in this particular point
fuel intake should be decreased
and
expenditure of the energy should be
increased
now when
mass of the adipose tissue increases
leptin secretion also increase
increased leptin secretion
inhibits feeding and fat synthesis
also it stimulates oxidation of fatty
acids
when
mass of the adipose tissue decreases
insulin secretion
and also the
leptin secretion decreases
this results in greater food intake
and less fatty acid oxidation
now you must be wondering that you are
eating a lot
but
your friend which is
very lean
he eats a lot but never get fat
why is so
so
obesity is is not directly proportional
to the calorific input
it turns out there are complex genetic
neuronal and hormonal mechanism that
regulates our feeding and fasting
behavior
leptin modulates our hunger circuit
in simple words
we have two different categories of
neuron in our hunger circuit
anorexigenic neuron and oxygenic neuron
or oxygenic neurons promote
eating whereas and oxygenic neurons
inhibit eating
leptin positively stimulates the
anoxygenic neuron or eat less neurons
and negatively stimulates
eat more neurons as a consequence
our hunger feeling is suppressed when
leptin is more
and we
end up spending more and more calories
now
this leptin
or the leptin receptor is encoded by
genes so any mutation in leptin gene or
the gene that produce leptin receptor
could be the underlying cause of obesity
as well
this is a list of genes that are
associated with obesity as per cdc
so now we understand
that underlying obesity there could be
several several reasons one of that
could be genetic as well and recent
research has shown beyond genetics
epigenetic mechanisms are also involved
in obesity
all these genetic and epigenetic
mechanisms are not in our control but we
can modify our lifestyle we can restrict
our calorific input we can increase our
exercise to manage our body weight
nowadays intermittent fasting is really
popular
practice to reduce your body weight and
keep a check on it
intermittent fasting can help in weight
loss and weight management in obese
individuals in intermittent fasting you
fast for 16 hours approx and you have a
feeding window of 8 hours
this ensures body can utilize
all the fat in during this fasting
period and it can break down the fat to
make energy if you want to learn more
about intermittent fasting you can click
on the video in the eye button
other than intermittent fasting dietary
modification such as keto diet low carb
diet could be useful
for weight loss if you want to learn
more about that you can again click on
the i button so in this video we learned
many things about obesity we learned
that obesity is a common disease it's
kind of like a lifestyle disease which
is affecting
every age group in our population
obesity can be genetic and sporadic as
well we also looked at the underlying
mechanisms that can trigger obesity we
learned about leptin as a regulator of
hunger behavior and calorific input so
if you like this video give it a big
thumbs up don't forget to support me on
patreon if you're an indian viewer you
can support me in
bim upi your contribution means a lot
for me
and you can subscribe to my channel you
can share with your friends you can like
it and don't forget to let me know in
the comment how you like my videos by
the way my courses are also present in
an academy so you can use my code ap 10
to get a 10 discount thank you